ok Rachel, s'il te plaît, aide-moi à découvrir ce qui t'est
arrivé. J'ai besoin de ton aide. Qu'est-ce qui
se passe là-bas ?
Les morts sont mes patients. Je les traite
avec respect mais
tu dois leur parler. Tu dois toucher quelqu'un de vivant
de temps en temps.  pendant que
je réfléchis davantage aux raisons pour lesquelles les gens meurent, c'est
tout ce que je fais Mike Webster avait abandonné
sa famille s'était penché sur le chaos financier
et l'itinérance toute la ville était
sans travail c'était un gars qui nous donnait de l'espoir alors
qu'il n'y avait vraiment aucun espoir un
arrêt cardiaque peut-être comment  il est mort mais pas comme
Mike je ne peux pas faire ça seul
je dois dire au monde ce qui
t'est arrivé oh mon dieu je pense que j'ai découvert une
maladie que personne n'a jamais vue avant de l'
utiliser se comporte comme une arme
tu dois continuer  pour que je puisse
continuer, je dois mourir,
malheureusement, des
familles sont déjà en train d'être détruites en ce moment,
malas, je suis allé à la presse maintenant, une première
page de votre temps si je continue à parler,
les choses pourraient devenir très difficiles, personne ne
vous en voudrait si vous  arrêté personne
n'arrête rien ce qui se passe maintenant ce que
vous pensez qu'ils vous font
ce n'est rien de mieux laissez tomber ou ils
feront votre autopsie mr.  Dr O'Malley.
Omalu entendant la guerre avec l'une des
plus grandes sociétés du monde,
tu continues à nier mon travail, tes hommes
continuent de mourir,
dis-leur ce qui se passe réellement,
dis la vérité, Charlie Truth,
je pense que tu vas être un
frappeur américain, tu n'es même pas américain.
c'est même mieux